everywhere you turn the Democrats and
their fawning media enablers are
elevating the concerns of non Americans
over actual Americans now last night as
I said I interviewed the parents of 15
year old Nyssa Mickens who was murdered
by illegal alien ms-13 gang members they
were president Trump's guests at
Tuesday's State of the Union I asked
them what they thought about the
Democrats failure to stand when they
were recognized I thought it was a very
disrespectful for the simple fact the
Democratic still was there who did not
stand up there were african-americans
they did not have the respect or to
honor what just happened to our lives
into America's lives regardless of how
they feel about the president they
should show the respect because I was
show them the respect if that was their
loved one so classy and so moving
president Trump was right to address the
brutality of the Salvadoran gangs
victimizing law-abiding innocent
Americans and he also highlighted the
otherwise forgotten victims among them
of course all liberal media types could
do in response to all this let's just
dismiss it as just now come on ms-13
that's thread that threats kind of
overblown its political hype and this is
mom reacted to that sentiment within
credulity I have no words I mean these
are gang members that just you know
decided to be a judge in a jury to take
my daughter out like that it's
unacceptable oh I don't want to tap it
to anybody else's family
oh it was so heartbreaking yet for most
Democrats these victims and their
families they're almost invisible the
anguish of those families is really
inconvenient to the storyline that a lot
of people on the Left like to tell that
illegal immigrants are all good and
they're all deserving of amnesty
benefits care
compassion etc liberals empathy though
only seems to go one way the awful awful
awful pictures of dreamers being
deported I think will rally the nation
for me the first step begins by finally
addressing the needs of dreamers it's a
priority that too long has been pushed
to the backburner we heard more
insulting words of ignorance and
Prejudice prejudice toward patriotic
immigrant families last night yeah cuz
those are American families they're not
patriotic at all Nancy oh and by the way
raise your hand if you're weary of the
endless immigration sob stories trotted
out by media coast-to-coast
a crowd of rabbis priests pastors and
immigration organizations sing and pray
for Luis Blanco on the outside you
wouldn't know this may be the last time
he'll see his family on American soil
honestly I didn't sleep well it's a very
difficult day it's a day where a big
decision will be made and I'm not sure
how it's gonna end
Blanco has called Plant City home for
two decades back in 1998 he was deported
and the next year he came back illegally
to find work Blanco has six
american-born children and a seventh on
the way so you heard that
first of all Blanco is here at 20 years
does not speak English was deported once
only to come back again illegally and
his 30 year old wife is a daca recipient
by the way now contrary to what
Democrats have tried to do to brainwash
generations of African Americans to
believe that Republicans are racist
terrible heartless people they've done
the same with Hispanics as well think
about this it's only Donald Trump who
had the guts to point out that an
unenforced border hits black Hispanic
and working poor generally
disproportionately hard lowering wages
shutting a lot of people out of entire
job sectors and of course the crime so
playing the crass game of identity
politics what Democrats do is they
create their own classes of imaginary
victims so illegal immigrants
anxiety about about deportation as you
just saw in that piece it's covered
endlessly and with maximum emotion lots
of sympathetic nods from reporters and
politicians stand and applaud for
so-called dreamers demanding rights and
if you disagree and you believe in
immigration measures that are designed
to benefit the American people well
you're smeared values you have very
hostile anti-immigrant voices in the
house last week President Trump and DHS
secretary Neilson made another shameful
anti-immigrant decision by ending
temporary protected status for 31,000
Salvadorans we have a Republican
president Republican Senate a Republican
House all three of the most
anti-immigration that there is now
that's completely absurd Chuck and I'm
gonna throw it right back in his face
I'll ask him this our Democrats anti
children when they fail to stand up for
victims
such as the seven-year-old Indiana girl
who was repeatedly raped this month by a
24 year old illegal alien and by the way
if we have the picture of an away the
fixed areas and was this animal a
dreamer that's my question
well no most of course most illegal
immigrants don't commit serious violent
crimes we all know that but they do
comprise 22 percent of our federal
prison population that is a fact
and by the way a new study of Arizona
residents by economist John Lott finds
that illegal immigrants are 142 percent
more likely to be convicted of a crime
than other Arizonans Wow that is obscene
now today we have a thing called a catch
and release policy it's completely nuts
under which ice agents must release
unaccompanied and accompanied alien
children back into the country so
they're caught at the border and then
the process quickly and released back
into the United States Health and Human
Services
then resettles these kids in communities
and in states like yours we
released 100,000 of these unaccompanied
minors into the United States
just since fiscal year 2016 unbelievable
and a recent HHS study showed that the
majority of unaccompanied illegal alien
minors are 15 to 17 years old and
they're males in other words as that
Northern Virginia gang task force fellow
a couple weeks ago on the and this show
said they are prime recruitment targets
for ms-13 President Trump to his credit
and to our benefit wants to end this
scourge
many of these gang members took
advantage of glaring loopholes in our
laws to enter the country as illegal
unaccompanied alien minors and wound up
in Kayla and niece's high school tonight
I am calling on Congress to finally
close the deadly loopholes that have
allowed ms-13 and other criminal gangs
to break into our country I was thinking
about this too the Congressional Black
Caucus and all those Democrats who set
fuming rather than standing in support
of grieving American families Tuesday
night I say shame on you you've gone so
far left that you've left America and
that's the angle